هذا الطريق الى خرص المدينه الجنوبيه
حاضره ولايه انتاج البطيخ الذي اصبح بعد
ذلك رمزا لتحريرها سيطر الروس على هذه
المدينه في ذات تاريخ اجتياح الكامل
للاراضي الاوكرانيه وظل يسيطرون عليها
لتسعه اشهر حتى اجبرهم الاخرانيون عن
التخلي عنها بعد انقادوا هجوما مضاده بدات
اثاره واضحه على الطريق وقطعوا خطوط
الامداد خلف الروس فانسحبوا منها
خاصه القرى والبلدات والمناطق السكنيه
القريبه من ناردينو لان الاعداء موجود
مباشره عند الضفه الاخرى ويقومون باطلاق
النار على مواقعنا بالصواريخ والمدفعيه
وبكل انواع الاسلحه تعيش المدينه في ظروف
انسانيه صعبه للغايه معظم الاحياء تعاني
من انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وامدادات
المياه والغاز
في ابل ونقص في الغذاء يهدد السكان
ولا تدفئه لكننا سنعيش في هذه الظروف افضل
من ان نعيش في وجود الروس نحن شعب حر ونحب
بلدنا اوكرانيا المجد الاوكرانيا والمجد
للابطال في
المدينه تدفئه ولا مياه ولا كهرباء ولا
شبكه اتصالات ولا انترنت الوضع صعب لكننا
مؤمنون بان كل ذلك سيعود قريبا
فصل الشتاء بدات في تفسير القوافل
الانسانيه وفتحت بابا النزوحي على نفقه
الدوله ترحيلا واسكالا واطعامها
من المحتلين لقد اتينا هو احضرنا
المساعدات الانسانيه وايضا المتخصصين من
ولاياتنا الذين سيبقون هنا لمساعده
المدينه في اعاده امدادات الطاقه والمياه
وكل ما يحتاجه الناس للعيش بشكل طبيعي
هنا في ساحه المدينه الرئيسيه في خرسون
رسميا رفع الرئيس الاوكراني يفلا دمر
زيليسكي على ما بلاده في حضور قواته
المسلحه التي ما انفرغت من السيطره على
المدينه حتى باشرت عمليه سد الثقوري
وتعزيز الدفاعاته اما المدنيون فيقولون
انهم باقون في موطنهم رغما عن الظروف
لقناتي العربيه والحدث وليس عادل خرسون